hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning Paul Canton
just checking in on you oh how was your
week going hey man it's almost hey man
dig it man
it's almost [ __ ] Friday right then
you know next week you got this short
week short like your uncle plays that
crazy D every time you play [ __ ]
basketball a little hairy [ __ ] running
all around you know always ends up on
the skins team going by yeah just a
[ __ ] I meant one time playing [ __ ]
pick-up hoop way back in the day and
there was just this mountain of a man on
the other team and who had no shame and
it was shirts and skins and we wanted to
be like hey buddy you're fat enough that
we're not gonna forget you and we're
gonna remember that you're on the other
team but nope he was like hey I don't
want any preferential treatment I want
to be treated just like everybody else
okay [ __ ] pocket T cuz what else is a
giant [ __ ] person gonna wear but a
pocket tee shout out the people who make
pocket teeth you know helping fatties
around the world sweatpants and pocket
tees you know shout out to the people
that designed the dimensions for those
four you know and then hand them off to
those poor people that make $3 a month
to sew that giant you know they probably
say in some sort of different language
other than English why would you put a
pocket on a tarp it's actually we'll be
right back with chatter questions in a
sweatshop after these messages I think
that's a show that should be on lifetime
and I think Tara
Reid should host it or Brooke Burke
remember all those shows back in the day
and those travel things or didn't re
take over for Brooke Burke didn't I do a
bit about that with ku Mia way back in
the day and Opie and Anthony I don't
remember I have old brain was that a
week ago was that ten years ago or did
it happen to somebody else or did it
never happen I was reading about the
Nazi hunters this morning on my phone I
picked up my phone see if I had any text
messages and next thing you know I was
on the internet and next thing you know
I was I was reading about Adolf Eichmann
how does that happen I don't know I have
no idea maybe my wife was was asking for
a pair of boots for Christmas you know
and I clicked on boots and then it was
like who had the greatest boots of ever
of ever ever sorry not of ever who had
the greatest boots ever and then if you
read enough on boots eventually you're
gonna end up with the Nazis yeah and
there'll be some fashionista out there
that's gonna be talking about you know
as much as what they did was horrible I
got to tell you they look really sharp
when they were doing it and then next
thing you know you're reading about
Adolf Eichmann I don't think that's how
it went down but I find that fascinating
that uh that after World War Two for
whatever [ __ ] reason what is it about
South America what is it about them that
there's such an empathetic continent
that even they could see the good in the
Nazis you know okay yes he instrumental
in at least you know five hundred
thousand deaths himself you know but
here's something else you might want to
take in consideration do you know he's
really into sailing you know he actually
paid sport returners I mean let's let's
try and judge the whole person yeah I
know there any movies about that I have
seen some like
documentaries on that but I don't know
it's just that just fascinates the hell
out of me that let me talk about the
ultimate [ __ ] fugitive I mean these
serial killers what do they get up
thirty forty pedestrian numbers he's
[ __ ] you're sittin there walking
around trying to blend into society and
you've killed five hundred thousand
[ __ ] people hey what's your name Oh
Frank
and then then was sad where they would
they would somehow track these [ __ ]
people down you know and they would they
would then observe them in and double
check to make triple check what make
sure it's the right [ __ ] person then
they had to kidnap them out of the
[ __ ] country like they drugged Adolf
Eichmann and somehow dressed him as a
flight attendant which I don't get it
someplace like some weekend at Bernie's
[ __ ] and you know you know why is this
guy passed out ah don't worry he's not
the pilot he's just a flight attendant
ha ha ha and then they [ __ ] got him
out of there and oh I know how I ended
up doing this this is how I got up to
[ __ ] Eichmann was I went on to
Twitter and once again someone was
tweeting something about whatever was
going on with Trump but I had no idea
what it was I've read it
Patton Oswalt retweeted something about
the New York Times then it was the it
was the front page and I read the whole
thing and none of it meant anything to
me because they wouldn't actually say
what was going on and they're assuming
that you've been following this story
which I haven't been and then it's a
politician answering questions trying to
implicate somebody else while keeping
his own ass out of the sling so it was
very vague speak but he did he used the
expression I was following orders so of
course everybody jumps on that and like
flowery legs
and yeah I think my next search in the
next thing you know I was reading about
those [ __ ] guys
I guess the Angel of Death guy that
piece of [ __ ] he actually [ __ ] died
of a stroke drowned while swimming they
never caught that [ __ ] I don't
know if anybody knows have a really good
doc I saw one documentary where they
followed this [ __ ] former Nazi guy
and they they finally cornered the guy
and there was like three of them and
they said the Mossad guys they stripped
out of their [ __ ] BVDs cuz they did
item for whatever they didn't want any
bloody clothes or whatever and they got
this guy and they honed in on his greed
or something and he wasn't making as
much money you know and he was the [ __ ]
when he was in [ __ ] Germany he had
all this [ __ ] that he stole or whatever
right so they could they bring him into
the room and it's the Joe Pesci moment
he thinks he's got to get may and he's
like ah now except there was no guns
they couldn't make any noise and they
started beating this guy and they said
he fought like a [ __ ] lion and there
was anything I was like in his 50s or
60s at that point it was at one point
there was actually a question of whether
they were gonna win the fight or not
and they finally got to God and it's
[ __ ] up is every time they caught one
of those guys then there would be all
this anti-semitic [ __ ] that happened
down in Brazil I had no [ __ ] idea you
know I thought everybody down there was
cool now I'm not judging the whole
goddamn continent you know but when your
foreign policies as [ __ ] up as ours
it's nice every once in a while to see
another continent doing some bad [ __ ]
granted it takes a whole continent I
think I'm talking about I went to the I
went to the Celtics game last night out
here and lost honglei's I saw the Boston
Celtics against the Los Angeles fukin
and this is hilarious the first half of
that game might have been the most
boring NBA game I ever went to
and what was hilarious was Floyd
Mayweather was sitting in the front row
at the game and I was too far
plus I also lacked the balls but I was
thinking a great heckle at that moment
in the game would have been like hey
Floyd the first half of this game is as
boring as your last 22 pay-per-view
fights when he turns around and looks at
you'd be like dude [ __ ] you I'm like
1,200 bucks in on you on absolute
snoozefest I get your little roll of the
shoulders you turn sideways oh nobody
can see you but you're right there poo
poo poo
having said that he's one of the Great's
of all time but Jesus did I get [ __ ]
over on a lot of paper views with that
guy so it was boring his [ __ ] I'm
sitting there laughing with my buddy the
whole time we're going to the game I go
they're gonna lose this game because I'm
not gonna lose they got a great [ __ ]
team by the way I don't even recognize
half the people on the [ __ ] team I
mean they really that say they shook it
up over there okay there was Jason Tatum
was still there Marcus smart try
everybody else seemed to be like
brand-new
who's this Brad Wanamaker is that he
said he had a great [ __ ] game
shout out to Daniel theas for actually
going up and trying to block a dunk
granted he got [ __ ] you know post
arrives as they said back in the day but
uh I like that he actually challenged
him Leonard my god was a [ __ ] monster
dunk that was like right in front of us
- I don't know but I like our team but I
was saying to my buddy go dude I've been
to this [ __ ] game since I've been out
in LA I've gone to this game like four
times and every time the Clippers would
whether a pre Blake Griffin they would I
saw the big three Blake Griffin might
have been there like ten years ago the
big three I went out there and they
[ __ ] I went to the game and they
[ __ ] lost to a no-name clipper team
and this is basically the deal okay I've
found with Boston teams when they go out
there
if the Bruins come out and they got like
Anaheim and then the Kings or then the
Kings and then Anaheim one of the games
are going to win
one of the game's gonna be a stick cuz
there's just too much talent out there
and I'm not talking about the teams if
you know what I mean okay they see the
Hollywood sign they see the glitz some
of the top [ __ ] ash a lot of work out
there and I that is my theory they come
out there they [ __ ] around I mean I I
knew these guys that worked for another
NBA team and they used to bring their
NBA team they try to keep him down
Manhattan Beach they try to keep him
away from the horse so they could go in
there and get it W I don't think that
that's actually the issue cuz the first
out on the first half was like a [ __ ]
snooze fest and then in the second half
they came out guns ablaze and it went
into overtime it was a great game and I
tell you I really enjoyed watching Doc
Rivers work in the refs former self to
coach Lana hawk all of that one of the
[ __ ] hall-of-famer right that [ __ ]
guy me Brad Stevens was almost at half
court too but like he spent half the
game almost at half court and he has
such seniority they're not gonna tell
him to get back in the coach's box
between the end of the game and this
beginning of overtime he spent his
entire time working one of the refs and
the refs just sitting there listening to
it was that no point as a duck you might
want to go over and talk to your team
you want to win this [ __ ] game they
came out and and beat us but I gotta
tell you it was great there wasn't a lot
of overly look what I just did
celebrating I think the fact that
Leonard does what he does during a game
and doesn't [ __ ] barely even blink
and I think it makes everybody tone down
they're ripping open their shirts acting
as though they're turning into Superman
now no you're not no you know you're
really not anyway do you think the
mossad did that and when they caught one
of the [ __ ] Nazi hunters do you think
they then pretended to [ __ ] a big if
they didn't do that if they didn't just
you're a guy that killed 500,000 of
their own [ __ ] people and they didn't
do a little [ __ ] you know whatever
the [ __ ] these kids that they learn
today then well how are you justifying
that after you just hit a three-pointer
I don't know anyway but after the game
was hilarious we walked out I mean my
lovely lovely wife you don't want the
game the couple friends of ours and I
was in such a good mood we actually live
instagrammed whatever the [ __ ] that is
live streamed just had a great [ __ ]
time and when we walked out we heard
there so it was just that mass of
humanity that they all funnel into one
area can we walk over here with this air
I could walk over I'm sorry I put down
with the bug that that [ __ ] horse
[ __ ] so it's like it's like I all right
you know so we all [ __ ] walk down
this one place and it's just every
[ __ ] person out there with [ __ ]
bedazzled horseshoes is trying to get an
uber out here in Los Angeles so we
decided to keep walking up the block and
we run into a cab and he goes well you
know it's high-traffic time it's gonna
be about 40 bucks when it should have
been 17 I just went all right
[ __ ] it you got me capitalism go ahead
so I [ __ ] get in the cab my lovely
wife we start going up the street and as
we're going up the street there's this
kid on a scooter and the cab driver just
shakes his head just going and just
basically started talking about how
[ __ ] dangerous and incredibly
reckless that is to do with you it is he
goes they're supposed to be over in the
bike lane this kid was like out in the
middle of the [ __ ] Road right
dark clothes on on a [ __ ] scooter
driving down the street went like people
are texting [ __ ] I don't think Evel
Knievel would do that at least he'd have
on was riding leathers and a helmet
right anyway so as we're driving they
ended up being this [ __ ] drunk
Clippers fan it was [ __ ] hilarious he
was walking in the middle of the street
just walking and he had his hands up
doing the with the number one fingers in
both hands because they just won game 12
of [ __ ] 81 games or whatever the [ __ ]
they play in the the NBA so it was a
great time great people watching and
that type of [ __ ] and Clippers games
underrated underrated great [ __ ]
sports fans Lakers games are fun if you
sit in the upper deck if you sit down
below there's just too many so many pile
on [ __ ] I don't know Real Housewives
vibes down there and I've always told
you this dis Staples Center is like the
king of like the haves and the have-nots
it's like you have the whole lower bowl
where you got to have money and then
there's just like three layers of
[ __ ] luxury boxes and then this
little [ __ ] upper deck way up top I
don't know I don't know whatever what do
I give a [ __ ] it's not my friend choice
right all right I got a couple of reads
here butcher box you know when it comes
to me quality matters but there's more
to it than texture and taste talk about
the hidden costs with low quality meat
our flavor costs to environment etc what
how do I know about the hidden costs a
local quality meat what am i a [ __ ]
butcher why is high quality humanely
raised meat important to you better for
you better for the animal better for the
environment what's your favorite cut of
meat I like the pork chop it's a lot of
questions with this how do you like to
prepare it a little salt and pepper
III sear it on the oven and a cast-iron
skillet I finished it in the oven then I
bring it back up top for a little butter
bath a little garlic butter bath maybe
some rosemary
not everyone has convenient access to
high quality meat luckily there's
butcher bucks butcher bucks believes
everyone deserves high-quality humanely
sourced me every month butcher bought
ships a curated section of high quality
meat right to my house all meat is free
eight guys I'm doing a recording here
no respect you mean you hear me you
think I mean they're talking to myself
about butcher books I mean obviously I'm
a this is a continuation of the show
every month butcher box ships me a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to my home all meat is free of
antibiotics and added hormones each box
has nine to eleven pounds of meat enough
for 24 individual meals unless you're a
fat bastard you probably get six pack
fresh and ship frozen and vacuum sealed
so it stays that way I can customize my
box or go with one of theirs either way
I get exactly what I want it's the best
meat shipped right to my door which goes
one less trip to the groceries you know
it's funny about this copy you switch a
couple of words and you're getting a
mail-order bride I can customize my box
it's delivered right some idea it's all
there options like 100% grass-fed and
finished beef free organic free-range
organic chicken heritage breed pork my
favorite wild-caught alaskan salmon you
don't know what they're gonna do and
sugar nitrate free bacon butcher box is
the most affordable convenient way to
get healthy humanely raised meat before
they kill it which butcher with butcher
bucks you can you get the highest
quality meat for just around six dollars
a meal and they even have free shipping
nationwide except Alaska and Hawaii
right now you can get two pounds of
ground beef
two packs of bacon absolutely free plus
$20 off your first box just go to
butcher box.com /tpour or use the promo
code bar at checkout that's butcher
box.com slash burrow or use the promo
code burr at checkout
all right Stan so this is a new one do
you remember when socks used to be one
of the worst things you could get at
Christmas
it went fruitcakes then socks then maybe
a gift certificate to a restaurant you
didn't like tell a story about a
horrible gift I've already done this a
million times I bought that chick a
[ __ ] polo shirt for her birthday she
said what the [ __ ] is this and started
yelling at me and I sat in the corner of
her bed while she scolded me it took me
about six minutes to get the self-esteem
to tell her to go [ __ ] herself and we
continued dating for about three months
after that for some reason well times
have changed because over the last few
years Stan's has completely changed the
reputation of sucks they took this piece
of apparel no one cared about and made
them something they Michael Jackson
cared about him that's why he wore such
short little pants there
I made them something people can't stop
talking about and they're now the go-to
gift for people who really want to make
someone feel happy during the holidays
the quality and detail that goes into
Stan's socks is incredible the design
ranged from simple to elaborate with a
ton of insanely cool collaborations like
their NBA and MLB collections Star Wars
the Mandalorian a I know a guy that's in
that thing maybe episode six
from what I heard the office elf
stepbrothers wu-tang Metallica and a lot
more how come they don't do it Billy
freckle suck um I don't know if you like
me but I find holiday shopping truly
painful why would they [ __ ] write
that they don't know me I do find it
incredibly painful nice guest stance
incredible design and comfort unmatched
durability casual everyday styles like
no one like no shows and cruise or
performance athletic products like no
shows I didn't want any of that means
official on-field sock of Major League
Baseball you know they are great socks
when Major League puts them on every
player's feet quality sucks for everyone
Stan's collaborates with great brands
artists athletes and cultural icons
we've already read all of these will add
Marvel Carhartt Star Wars Disney x-men
this is the longest [ __ ] copy ever my
listeners get a free pair of socks with
their next order all you have to do is
go to Stan's calm slash / that Stan's
calm slash / I can't think of a better
gift to get or give this holiday then
Stan's socks hey Nia how about I get you
some Stan's socks for Christmas yep do
that and in place of a diamond necklace
take that guesswork out of holiday shop
take the guesswork out of holiday
shopping stance makes gift-giving easy
and everyone will be happy Stan's calm
slash bar for all your holiday needs and
free socks with purchase
so anyway hey guess
Oh Billy freckles Oh freckled-faced [ __ ]
Oh is Sunday it'll be one year sober no
booze and I got to tell you last night
last night I almost accidentally drank a
beer I went up and I was you know
somebody we were with got us around a
[ __ ] and I got some waters and I got
some waters and then I [ __ ] went I
said all right I got to get around so I
went up to go get around and they poured
the beers into like these these big
plastic cups so as I was going like
they'd filled it up to the top which was
very nice of them usually they alligator
on me and it was gonna like spill onto
my hand so out of force a habit I almost
went down and just drank which would
have been bad on two levels one I'm
trying to stay sober but number one it
wasn't even gonna be my beer it's just
like muscle memory and I was like whoa I
almost did that and then I sort of
stared at the beer like who you know
like [ __ ] Homer Simpson mmm Donuts
right but I didn't I laid off so Sunday
is gonna be one year sober and Wednesday
will be my personal record for being on
the wagon 368 days breaking my former
record by one day you guys don't give a
[ __ ] I give a [ __ ] and I got to tell you
by the end of the game I was I'm really
kind of loving not being a drunk anymore
and just watching these people hammered
being like oh there's me there's me a
year ago seeing this old guy staring
hard at the ladies as they were leaving
you know like if you could get me to
just out of a look this [ __ ] guy's
career would be over
some drug hugging some arguments just a
lot of [ __ ] there was one Real Housewife
type chick having a hell of a time in
the shoes that she wore that would have
been good for a red carpet not good for
going up Stadium stairs walk she living
a baby giraffe you know when they first
start to learn how to walk with their
big dumb long legs but I don't know it
was definitely it was definitely a good
time and you don't I
found it kind as far as like a good
activity a nice bonding activity with my
wife is she really likes she likes going
to basketball games not into football
not into hockey not into baseball so it
is basketball so I was actually thinking
like you know I know maybe we could go
to a couple more Clippers games can't
really get myself to [ __ ] she probably
wants to go to a Lakers game maybe I'll
get her some Lakers whatever you know
what I mean you just learned you know
something bill just [ __ ] just just
why don't you choose easy every once in
a while you know that could be good I
want to go when either the Lakers or the
Clippers are playing the Houston Rockets
and every time Tatum takes us not Tatum
[ __ ] what's that guy's name the
[ __ ] bearded guy there you know what
I'm talking about every time that
bearded guy goes to take a [ __ ] shot
I'm just gonna yell the guy takes four
[ __ ] steps four [ __ ] steps what
the hell's his name there's a there is
the bearded guy there the [ __ ] is is
there I I just I have no [ __ ] I was
talking about him lat last night I knew
his name player sorry he'll come up
first right he oddly looks like Bill
Cosby when he reminds me a Bill Cosby
when he would grow that big beard James
Harden James Harden travel 1 2 3 4 shoot
I don't know let's let's let's try to
find out Trump
what is it Trump Inquisition trumping
inquiry there we go what is happening
explain please spell to explain run the
trumpet Pietschmann what happened today
the trumpet Pietschmann the new york
times impeachment hearings Trump Inc
read Trump impeachment what happened let
me try this I feel like with this thing
it's like Game of Thrones you haven't
watched it yet dude you got to get
caught up there's 500 [ __ ] episodes
impeachment broken down alright alright
come on help me out here
Pietschmann hearings Pietschmann inquiry
oh [ __ ] do Americans support impeaching
Trump news on Trump and Pietschmann
impeachment hearings putting Trump
through the emotional wringer it's the
greatest ringer ever one day he's down
then he's up Holmes its was clear to
Ukrainians that Giuliani was a force to
contend with yeah how did they get you
crane Ian's end up in this what the [ __ ]
I thought this was about that he stole
the election that the Russians used him
and then Giuliani's in there I thought
he was in New York making sure there was
no hookers on 42nd Street how did he
have time to talk to Ukrainians I mean
it seems like a really flimsy case to me
wait I mean let me let me let me try to
get down to the bottom of this let's say
to Americans support and P Qing Trump
well it depends on who you ask
I would think you're just gonna stick us
all in one basket impeachment hearings
live updates he'll my wife testified
homes Trump in yeah I mean how do you
get caught up
Trump impeachment explained ah come on
live updates live updates smoking gun in
the Trump impeachment an inquiry
explained and [ __ ] all you guys who are
laughing at me right now I know party
and some of you don't know this is all
right all right the impeachment inquiry
into the u.s. president Donald Trump
Trump's Ukraine dealings continues today
with Army lieutenant colonel Alexander
vid Minh director of European ababa but
the smoking gun in this case Trump's
July 25th phone call with ukrainian
President
oh boy Volodymyr falada mir zalenski
falada me a visit at szalinski mr ova
eliciting a favor it's already out and
has been for 11 months
Robert litt former general counsel for
the Director of National Intelligence
spoke to courts about the critical phone
call how it was stored and why it's so
important why it's said that the Trump's
administration administration's decision
to store the call record on national
security server rather than following
the usual communication protocols for
sus exchanges is suspect because it is
unusual in the criminal I don't know I
give up I don't give a [ __ ] I get like
you know see this is why this is what we
see right it's right here is why why I
don't try to be informed because I
actually you can see I actually tried
for a good 90 seconds to understand what
exactly is [ __ ] going on why they're
not letting that man run the country why
they're up his ass about some fender
bender that he had over in the [ __ ]
Ukraine okay we all know politics is a
dirty filthy stinking business and you
know I don't I don't understand they're
not going to
Peacham and no matter what comes out of
this people that support Trump are gonna
continue to support him they could
literally have him on a chat line
remember those those phone-a-friend
lines back in the 90s he could have done
phone-a-friend
with the [ __ ] Klan and Trump
supporters would still be like what
about Obama I mean he was half white how
do you know that half of him never I bet
half of him it called that [ __ ] phone
a friend Klan party line I mean that's
literally like yeah people do defend
Trump or defend Obama it's like trying
to get a fan of a team to recognize
anything wrong that their team did where
they can so obvious see the other
[ __ ] thing so I don't know how like
you can sit there and have the patience
to deal with that all right I don't know
I figure out what they said like I was
listening to some [ __ ] interview and
they were talking about that time when
Trump got trashed at that [ __ ] you
know but that's that thing that
everybody said this is the why he had
ended up running they stuck him right in
the middle of the room and they [ __ ]
trashed the ship they had a roast
who's some Obama thing right and
someone's going well you know Trump
deserved it I mean the way he was going
after Obama what the whole birthing
thing was horrible
and I wanted to be like I mean I didn't
think it was right that he spent it all
that [ __ ] time having to sit there
and prove that he was from here but
let's you know it's easy with the window
dressing all right Jimmy Carter was the
last [ __ ] decent human being
that was ever president and all you got
to do is look at all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] that were president what are
they all doing huh Jimmy Carter just
fell off a [ __ ] ladder and I'm like
[ __ ] it almost 90 years of age trying to
help underprivileged people have a place
to live what are all these other guys
doing they're out there giving speeches
make it 300
tonight going to Epstein Island [ __ ]
buying up aquifers in South America
they're all his [ __ ] wife's doing a
goddamn book tour Dressel yeah walking
out there dressing like she's gonna go
win a [ __ ] Oscar for being married to
some guy who did something right they're
all [ __ ] scumbags all right there you
go from somebody what other podcasts are
you gonna get this kind of [ __ ]
information on huh
I started off what I started off with
with shining a light on sweatshop labor
transitioned effortlessly and to Nazi
hunters only to double back to the NBA
and end on Donald Trump in my indictment
on a bunch of people that ran this
country that I have no idea what they
did or didn't do
what a [ __ ] did Giuliani just keeps
popping up in these things you know he's
like the Heather Locklear of like
[ __ ] political figures remember
Heather Locklear like every [ __ ] like
she'd be on a show and then boom it
would make syndication and then she'd go
away and then there'd be another show
would come out and it wasn't doing well
and they'd stick her at syndication ah
the show I don't know might get
cancelled syndication that's what it is
I bet if you really investigated
Giuliani if they investigated him as
hard as they're investigating Trump like
now right now you would find that at
some point when he was a young man he
went to a taping a TJ Hooker I'm putting
that out there right now TJ Hooker
that's back when men were men
you know when they went by [ __ ] the
initials of their first in their middle
name and their last name was a reference
to a prostitute
okay and it was a bunch of butthurt
white chicks [ __ ] complaining about
it either
they went [ __ ] triggered they weren't
offended this man is TJ you're not to
look him or his toupee in the eye and
his last name is hooker okay and you got
to deal with it alright this is his
buddy
BJ strumpet I'm sorry anyways that is
the podcast here people for a Thursday
afternoon by the way I was watching a
little bit of hockey highlights last
night I have very very little time here
who's this [ __ ] guy in the avalanche
is a fastest guy in the league you see
that [ __ ] goalie had last night I
mean Jesus Christ I mean that looked
like how I dreamed that I looked like on
the ice back when I used to play pick-up
hockey do you know my [ __ ] hockey
stuff has been in my bag no it doesn't
smell cuz I always aired it out it's
been in my bag and I have not skated
since 2015 I haven't skated in four
[ __ ] years just like that you know
wife got pregnant you know I [ __ ] up
my back and then we had a kid and then
my shoulders went and I haven't done a
[ __ ] thing I got to get back out
there the problem is is the only time he
can play to get like ice time is 11:30
at night and you got to play to like one
in the [ __ ] morning then you come home
and you just lay in there you're wired
out of your mind until 3:00 in the
morning then your kid gets up at 7:00
well that's just a recipe for debt does
that even combine that with the fact
that no matter how much I play I still
thought hockey eventually you know
something's gotta give
alright that's it I'm gonna spend the
day with my lovely wife you know cuz you
know what god dammit I can't
I'm gonna be down Largo tonight I think
it's already sold out but uh I'll be I
think I'm down the lab factory this
weekend too if you guys want to see me
working out
some of my new she all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday yeah
Oh his is a little bit of music here
right a little bit of [ __ ] music bed
and then after that we're gonna have a
bonus half hour Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
from a Thursday earlier this year or 10
years ago I don't know how this off
[Music]
cause I wear a silly grin the moment you
come into view whatever the [ __ ] they
say next
I don't know doobie doobie Doo
hey it's bill Birds the Monday morning
podcast from Monday November 21st 2011
and I'm singing Christmas songs why the
[ __ ] would I be singing Christmas songs
when Thanksgiving hasn't even happened
yet you know why cuz I went out to the
mall this today I went out to the mall
oh my god let's go to the [ __ ] mall
and look at [ __ ] we don't need
I want to dress out my [ __ ] in a
different way give me a credit card mom
so sick of the same [ __ ] clothes I
want something that shows more of my
[ __ ] clique cleavage mom it's
acceptable now you don't understand I
went to the [ __ ] mall today and
that's all they're doing the plain
[ __ ] Christmas music they got the
goddamn fake [ __ ] trees up you know
Thanksgiving hasn't even happened yet I
want to know why I want to know why
every [ __ ] year Thanksgiving gets
more and more disrespected just getting
slapped around nobody gives a [ __ ] you
know what it is well you know why I love
Thanksgiving is because those [ __ ]
[ __ ] on Madison Avenue have never
found out a way how to make money off of
it they just can't you sit down and you
[ __ ] eat and then you watch football
and just lay there like a tub of [ __ ] it
is a [ __ ] greatest goddamn holiday
ever
it's the [ __ ] best you don't have to
buy anything you know do anything just
put something remotely respectable on to
cover your [ __ ] man tits go over to
somebody's house and just eat like a
goddamn animal you know then you sit
down you watch football I mean those
sons of [ __ ] cannot figure out a way
how to sell you [ __ ] they can't figure
out a way to make you go out and go to
the [ __ ] mall and buy [ __ ] so what
these [ __ ] have done and I think that's
because because a turkey doesn't have a
lap that was the big that was the big
deal breaker if they could somehow fit
oh maybe they can get like an emaciated
turkey maybe a turkey does have a lap
but they're just so [ __ ] fat you know
you can't get a kid to sit on it or even
have a person dress up like a [ __ ]
you know Turkey and just sit there you
know freaking kids out you know just
sitting there mom I don't want to do it
you know some big ugly turkey just
[ __ ] sitting there some struggling
actor in there trying to get some
goddamn [ __ ] I don't know you can't
make money off Thanksgiving I absolutely
love it and these [ __ ] realise it so
what they do is they put the Christmas
trees up beforehand you know and then
right after they have these psycho sales
for the [ __ ] legs right and they all
over here somebody gets trampled to
death you know some poor guy that sews
that social secur the [ __ ] security
guard that one year already went up he
was working at the Kmart you know Jimmy
[ __ ] 2,000 keys and he comes walking
up with his big [ __ ]
gymnast ring full of keys he unlocks the
door what happens he gets trampled by a
bunch of goddamn fatties who want to go
in there and try and buy a [ __ ] VCR
for nine dollars you know I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm going with this all I
know is I love Thanksgiving and I got
Christmas music in my [ __ ] head a
deado sleigh bells ring a link take take
take a leak to come on it's lovely
weather but then I guess they're playing
Johnny Mathis those were all Johnny
Mathis once um whatever Happy
Thanksgiving everybody
don't start your Christmas shopping
don't get an early start
don't do it wait what are you getting an
early start for this dis [ __ ] frenzy
why are you participating you know have
you wondered that why are you going
online late at night trying to see if
they released a couple of more iPhones
why are you doing that why are you going
to sporting events and when the [ __ ]
goddamn mascot comes up with the t-shirt
gun why are you leaning over that old
person in front of you stretched out
like a starving child and they're
shooting a [ __ ] pretzel roll at you
it's a goddamn t-shirt you know have
some [ __ ] respect for yourself you
want a t-shirt you walk into a Foot
Locker like a [ __ ] gentleman and you
mosey on over to the 9 million that they
have there that costs like $3 each
because somehow they figured out a way
to make [ __ ] toddlers sew them
together at 3:00 in the morning over in
Vietnam that's how you get a t-shirt you
don't make a [ __ ] ass of yourself in
front of your friends or even worse you
goddamn kids all right now you [ __ ]
douchebags [ __ ] douchebags trying to
get this goddamn iPhone for what
everybody's gonna have one in six weeks
all right they got like [ __ ] they got
like 20 cargo ships right off the coast
filled with them just just in a holding
pattern
just trying to work up the [ __ ] nerd
frenzy and what are you doing you're
buying into it go [ __ ] yourself
ghost of Steve Jobs okay you want me to
buy your phone
[ __ ] Oh put it in the goddamn store
stock your [ __ ] shelves all right
when you got plenty of them then you
[ __ ] call me and I'll go down and get
you goddamn phone you [ __ ]
you recently dead son of a [ __ ] you're
gonna [ __ ] sit there now you know
it's [ __ ] ridiculous I I have
listened to [ __ ] Bobby Kelly dude
they got plenty of them dude get out of
this door dude and I [ __ ] go down
there and they don't have them and they
go you know we release a couple if you
can if you go to our website dude [ __ ]
your website sir don't use that language
in this store this isn't a [ __ ] store
store has stuff that I can buy I don't
walk into a store and then you tell me
to go to a computer back at my house
right this is still a store right why
don't you [ __ ] call me when you when
you got the [ __ ] that I want sit here
play your [ __ ] games
you know I don't I know that you didn't
come up with it
with your stupid genius t-shirt yeah how
much of a [ __ ] discount did they give
you on the [ __ ] iPhone for you to
play ball huh Seth for you to sit here
and lead people around like this and
create this artificial [ __ ] frenzy
for these goddamn phones really you came
out with a new phone and you only made
18 of them you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
sticking with the Droid ROI I'm sticking
with this thing you know I like the
Droid because if you want one you can
just walk over and buy it I want to hear
from any of you [ __ ] who listen to my
podcasts going yeah he's going here and
yet you just pre-order I'm not [ __ ]
doing that all right I got too much [ __ ]
to do during the course of the day to
[ __ ] sit here and and start filling
out packing lists like I'm working in
their warehouse I don't work for those
[ __ ] down at the ice store whatever
the [ __ ] you call it [ __ ] them [ __ ]
their phone ok I'm gonna get one I'm
gonna get one after the first of the
year but all you dumb [ __ ] out there
who spent way too much money on people
you don't really give a [ __ ] about you
know so once again you got to be asking
yourself as the holiday season
dooby-dooby-doo and ski lollipop stick
it up your damn [ __ ] right it's coming
up there's a bunch of [ __ ] in your life
it's unavoidable all right that's what
makes a good [ __ ] a good [ __ ]
you know is is is the the sea of [ __ ]
that you have to you have to go through
to get to that one good [ __ ] all right
so you I know you got a bunch of [ __ ]
in your life and I know you have to play
the game you gotta get him something all
right
what you need to do is get him something
of sort of quality that doesn't cost a
lot of money and you can stuff it in
there [ __ ] stalking and just imagine
your gym and it done that throat and
I'll tell you right now
I can't think of a better [ __ ] gift
then the bill burr let it go DVD how do
you like that how do you like that 10
minutes of ranting against the man and I
become 10 minutes later there you go you
just saw an entire the first two acts of
a movie I'm struggling I'm struggling
and then I become the guy and then I
become a douche and then we go into the
third act and we got to see if if I'm
gonna come to my senses and help the
little man and get back with my
girlfriend that I left standing at the
bus stop in my hometown and dump that
fake tit at [ __ ] I met out in Glendale
or am I just gonna be a douche I don't
know studio wants a happy ending yeah
get him a [ __ ] DVD
it's 20 bucks bing-bang-boom you'll wrap
it up here you go here's some laughs go
[ __ ] yourself we'll see you next year
it's just a suggestion you don't have to
do it you know it's been a while since
I've horde myself out on my own podcast
you know was the last time I brought up
the donation button you know god I wish
I knew some donation music has anybody
ever made a song about giving didn't
Phil Collins make one some song about
homeless people Oh think twice yeah cuz
it's another day for you and me in
paradise
I don't think I've ever hated Phil
Collins more than when he wrote that
[ __ ] song you know I hate when people
do [ __ ] like that
I mean Sussudio was bad enough but don't
[ __ ] bring up homeless people I'm
sitting at home trying to have a
sandwich trying to enjoy my life and you
got to bring up the misery of all these
other [ __ ] people you know like every
one of them was a great guy and then you
know somebody put him out on the street
homeless people are just like people
with houses most of them are [ __ ] okay
I'm telling you there's a reason they're
outside there's a reason these [ __ ]
people are outside all right they got no
manners they don't wash you think they
got that dirty you think they got that
[ __ ] dirty a couple weeks out on the
street me a break the outside was
cleaner when those [ __ ] were living
inside and his phil college sitting in
his goddamn castle gonna tell me to
think twice i'm gonna think [ __ ] you
phil collins
you know why don't you rent out [ __ ]
a couple thousands of your rooms and you
goddamn tower you could solve the whole
[ __ ] homeless problem in manchester
there's a city in [ __ ] England right
um
what a beast of a drum of that guy huh
Phil Collins [ __ ] amazing he's got
his own sound plays those concert Tom's
still I love that he's stuck with them
there's a couple of drummers that I love
that never gave in to whatever was cool
at the time you know John Bonham went
right through the 70s as everybody was
muting the [ __ ] out of their drums and
everybody getting that dry sound
he was like yeah go [ __ ] yourself right
and he he actually went from a 24 to a
26 inch bass drum right right and that
right ladies this is compelling isn't it
for females to be listening to Phil
calls there's another guy he played
those those concert toms I think with no
bottom head like [ __ ] 19 of them
going all the way around the only guy
ever saw more toms going around it was
Nicko McBrain and iron made he didn't
give a [ __ ] Nicko McBrain is another guy
he's been playing that [ __ ] I mean
how many times do you knee
I'll tell you right now big chunk the
rain forest gets removed every year
making a new kit for that [ __ ] guy
alright this is the podcast I do I want
to talk about this week oh Jesus I gotta
sit up here at some point I'm gonna get
some furniture down here in my little
rec room got a little rec room that no
homeless people are allowed in Oh think
twice hey you know Phil if I want to
think about homeless people why don't
you let me do it why are you making why
are you reminding me in my one-bedroom
apartment
[ __ ] [ __ ] I bet that's all you did
for homeless people didn't you you wrote
a song about him and then you made you
made a meal you made millions of dollars
off of their [ __ ] problems oh he
lives in a box
chi-ching right it's [ __ ] brilliant
that's like Sally Struthers a lot of
people don't know this she has made an
absolute fortune over there in Ethiopia
and Somalia absolute [ __ ] fortune she
was gonna say trying to think how she
could have made money off those
broke-ass people she cuts off the ends
of her hair that's what she does and she
sells them to the lady
and then they they glue it on down on
knitter whoo huh
you know so they can be a little more
exotic not be just another run in the
mill Ethiopia
you know um they can have a little
famous hair down there there's no you
know some weeks I feel like I can talk
for [ __ ] three hours and it's not
gonna be a problem
this is one of these weeks I'm 15
minutes in and I don't know where the
[ __ ] I'm going next what did I do this
week did anything interesting happen you
know what I actually just spent I didn't
go out last night and then I spent the
entire day inside today and it was
raining out I got I don't know what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me if I'm on the road
and I'm working and I'm coming back and
I got auditions and I'm just moving I am
fine I am a happy smiling jackass but
the second I stopped moving it's over if
I don't have something to do within six
hours the thoughts that creep into my
head are just you know it's unbelievable
Oh son I'll just be sitting there
watching TV and I'm just be like you
could always kill myself yeah that's
always an option not say I'm gonna do it
you know that's why I get real depressed
when I have nothing to [ __ ] do I
swear to god I have to go work out I got
to do something to get my blood going
because the second I stopped moving you
know when I become like a little still
little puddle you know water not moving
while the animals not willing to drink
out of me because all the bacteria in
there right I [ __ ] I start thinking
about that [ __ ] I start thinking about I
am older than everybody in the NHL I
start thinking about all the time it's
gone by I start thinking about all the
all the time that's left I start feeling
I'm in the middle of this [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] am i doing and I got to talk myself
off a ledge I try to stay present you
know I'm really not big on going into
the past
you know that'd be like Terry Bradshaw
looking back at the early of the early
part of his career why would you do it
nothing but failure not suggesting that
I've won four championships but I did
Carnegie last week that's got to be
worth a ring you know speaking of which
somebody actually gave me a great
dilemma a dilemma this week
they asked me let me see if I could
scroll down here say lay on the [ __ ]
floor bill would you rather give up your
podcast or bomb at Carnegie Hall I'm
talking zero laughs one hour of utter
silence and you can't cut the set short
ah no-brainer I would give up this
podcast in a second there's no [ __ ]
way I am going down in that it that
would be a historic bombing you know you
don't know [ __ ] that I'm not doing that
it's just a stupid podcast and I can
that and everybody I know has a podcast
so I would just become a go-to guest on
everybody else's podcast and I would
Kenai rip it rip it up at [ __ ]
Carnegie Hall no-brainer no [ __ ]
brainer you know what you think I was
gonna choose my loyalty to you sir huh
was the last time you went on the mmm
podcast calm and you made a donation for
just 99 cents you can feed a podcaster
um so you guys watch a little NFL
football did you yeah I had a brutal
week betting brutal week so far I I've
been beaten [ __ ] Paul virzi so far
this year but you know I've been having
a nice run so you know gambling works
you know you guys know how gambling
works basically it goes around in
circles you're killing it you're killing
it and then you [ __ ] eat it and you
eat it and you always eat it more than
you kill it and that's how they [ __ ]
make money you're an absolute [ __ ]
SAP if you gamble if you look at the
World Series of Poker and you look at
people who gamble for a living you can
the ups and downs in their wardrobe they
got some piece of [ __ ]
rayon shirt with like $100,000 watch on
their wrists you know to doll it to pay
and for Nadal the sunglasses they're the
worst
it's just a [ __ ] degenerate loser
[ __ ] thing to do you're not gonna win
you're never getting your money back
just stop you know but you know what it
is it's them I don't know how it works
with the ladies but with guys it's the
[ __ ] ego guys with it with idiots we
think we have a system we think we know
what we're doing we don't I'll tell you
what's his face virzi drives me up the
[ __ ] wall we will make making our
bets today right and I said I was taking
buffle off today against Miami and right
as we hung up he goes dude update I
think Miami's gonna kill him right I'm
really think Miami's gonna put a beating
on him okay then we hang up and there
was heat text me later when Miami puts a
beatin on he goes do what I called it
right it's like dude we were just
betting games we're betting games why
don't you [ __ ] put your money where
your mouth is bet the Dolphins and then
say dude I called it don't [ __ ] do
that throw away [ __ ] right before we
hung up I said I like the Redskins today
but I didn't bet on him so I didn't text
him and say dude I called it what he
should have said was dude I bitched up
really I hope you're listening to this
virzi really you called it so what you
wanted those two losers instead what
about Tim doe geez Tebow romp there's
another one verse he called dude I'm
telling you the [ __ ] Jets are gonna
kill him I'm gonna tell you guys right
now and don't tell virzi this this is
why I'm gonna beat him this year like I
beat him last year Paul verzino watch
I'm gonna [ __ ] lose like 20 in a row
Paul virzi makes the brutal mistake of
always betting on what should happen you
know I don't get it
I don't get it he [ __ ] every [ __ ]
week he bets what should happen okay
like take tomorrow night Patriots versus
the [ __ ] Kansas City Chiefs everybody
who's ever watched a football game in
their life says the Patriots are gonna
kick the living [ __ ] out of the Chiefs
[ __ ] Patriots are given 15 [ __ ]
points dode it's a lock
[ __ ] Tom Brady it's a home game
Monday night they're on a roll
matt cassel isn't playing everything
write down a [ __ ] checklist of the
Patriots winning the amount of [ __ ]
times in that scenario the Chiefs will
cover is [ __ ] it's I swear to god it
feels like it's off the charts so what
you have to do every week in my world
there's like five games of can you
[ __ ] believe that can you [ __ ]
believe all virzi never takes into
consideration can you [ __ ] believe
that he never bets on can you [ __ ]
believe that he goes on the height he
bets height and he bets with his heart
which I can't I can't fault him for that
you know he bets what should happen
despite the fact that we live in this
corrupt [ __ ] world despite the fact
you go to Vegas the lights are on all
night all day the [ __ ] ac's crankin
with the doors wide open the middle of a
[ __ ] desert
despite that he never takes what the
[ __ ] into consideration I on the other
hand do I will bet what the [ __ ]
which is why I am wile I'm always up a
couple of games on it don't up telling
you the Jets you know they [ __ ] lost
last week that going into Denver they
got [ __ ] Tebow the guy sucks [ __ ]
blah blah blah right there I run from
those games you [ __ ] run far there's
no [ __ ] way in hell I ever would have
put money on that bit on
game ever goddamn up and down Jets then
they're going to Tim Tebow it just looks
like a layup who in their right mind
wouldn't have bet the Jets that right
there is a [ __ ] red flag it's like
seeing some [ __ ] hot chick just
goddamn [ __ ] god she's an 11 standing
there and she doesn't have a boyfriend
she just get out of a relationship now
right right there [ __ ] red flag stay
away from it stay away from it so I took
the Kansas City Chiefs now I might get
[ __ ] burned on this all right but I'm
telling you in the long run you know
what's funny is I made fun of people
with the system now I'm telling you my
system in the long run I really believe
that you gotta throw those ones in if
you ever just want to go undefeated you
got it you gotta throw them in there you
got you got a bet somebody there's gonna
be a [ __ ] upset right look at Tampa
Bay this week who the [ __ ] saw that
coming all of a sudden they're gonna
play
nobody [ __ ] goddamn Packers were
favored by 15 and a half just sitting
there on the table I'm sitting there
looking at it going and now you know and
I was thinking Tampa Bay I was thinking
Tampa Bay but you know what I didn't
have the balls and I have the [ __ ]
balls to pull the trigger and I made the
mistake I bet on the bills who the bills
were and who the Dolphins were rather
than who they are right now and I got my
[ __ ] ass handed to me and I deserved
it and then I also took the Panthers
against the [ __ ] Lions I don't know I
just thought I don't know why I did that
I didn't realize that the Panthers had
no [ __ ] defense I had no idea you
know so I was open to coming out of the
gate I was like you got to be [ __ ]
me and the only thing that I believed in
is Jim Harbaugh and the 49ers Jim
Harbaugh is the [ __ ] man and when Jim
Harbaugh sets his sights on doing
something whatever it is it gets done
alright that [ __ ] guy I swear to God
he probably look at the spread and said
okay it's ten and a half not only do we
have an obligation to win this game we
got to make sure that people who
believed in us to put money on this team
are gonna make money wouldn't surprise
that's how [ __ ] competitive that
guy's I [ __ ] love that guy USC went
for a two-point conversion when they
were up by fifty six to nothing or
whatever and then Pete Carroll comes up
hey what's your problem
because you've been doing that to us for
years go [ __ ] yourself I was like I like
that guy so that was the favor and I
took so I'm actually having a bad week
I'm 1 & 2 right now when oh Jesus so
tomorrow night I got the Chiefs getting
15 I don't know why I just got this
[ __ ] feeling because the Patriots
should keep the picture should win that
game like [ __ ] you know I don't know
what 30-something the [ __ ] you know
thirteen or ten one of those games you
know those games in the fourth quarter
where they just the announcers just
start shooting the [ __ ] with each other
you know I'll tell you know year in and
year out you got a hand at this
franchise they just they are about
winning and it's and it's a it's it's a
tradition it's expected here and you
know when you look at a team like Kansas
City that tradition just you know it's a
proud franchise they have great fans you
know they always have to cover their ass
but you know it's just not that
sentiment is not in the locker room
that's what should happen so I was like
alright that's what the [ __ ] everybody's
gonna bet you know it's like the
earthquake thing all right every time no
California fall into the [ __ ] ocean
it isn't it's gonna be the East Coast
there's too much money on the west coast
everybody's been in the west coast
everybody bet the Patriots that means
the Giants are gonna win everybody bets
the Rams the [ __ ] Patriots are gonna
win every once in a while
Superbowl 20 that one panned out
I know other ones have whatever who
gives I'm a completely full of [ __ ]
anyways I just like breaking Versys
balls
Paul virzi who destroyed it Caroline's
not Caroline sorry Caroline's at [ __ ]
Carnegie um anyways let's get into some
other [ __ ] for this week what do we got
here what do we got here Oh last week I
asked you guys when we were talking
about fears and I was saying top fears
for a guy would be you know going to
prison getting raped
you know girlfriend cheating on you and
not being able to support your family so
I asked I asked some people out there to
send me their top ten lists all right
here we go top ten fears of two guys
here this is two people who sent them in
number one for this guy failure yeah
just straight across the board failure
you know that's got to be a quiet moment
when you just straight-up just failed I
always picture yourself standing like on
a boardwalk near a beach but it's not a
good beach it's a dirty Beach and it's
like you know hot dog wrappers getting
blown around some dirty seagull just
sitting there hypodermic needles and
[ __ ] he just looking out the ocean just
going should I do it should I just walk
out in there you know water so dirty
wanting to get eaten by anything you
just die slowly of hepatitis all right
number two getting sent to prison and
getting raped that's got to be on every
guy's list you know except for the guy
that does the rake can you imagine that
if you're if you're in prison and you're
raping another guy what a [ __ ] relief
that's got to be I can't believe my
whole life I was nervous about this
moment turns out I'm the guy I'm the guy
everybody should have been afraid of you
know I used to do a bit about that a
long time ago
like dude do
sike you do like serial killers get
Newark gets scared at night you know as
they walk through a park like oh jeez
you know I shouldn't be in the park late
at night you know that could be some
psyche oh wait it's me oh [ __ ] dude I'm
running [ __ ] you know start skipping
through the park if I was a cop that's
what I would do if I was a cop and I was
looking for a serial killer I would just
hide out in the park and I'd look for
some guy walking through the park who
didn't look like he had a [ __ ] care
in the world I mean that's the guy
that's the guy killing everybody he has
no reason to be nervous he's the guy
everybody should be afraid of
and he's not gonna hurt himself so there
you go long as he's not suicidal this
guy's got nothing to [ __ ] worry about
I'm all right next one what the [ __ ]
what did I do a I scrolled down I lost
it all right
fear number three being cheated on by
the woman I love oh that would be the
worst I said last week even worse
cheated on by the woman you love with
one of your friends you know that's
another reason why whenever I break up
with a bro
I get the [ __ ] away from them I get away
from them because you know not saying
all of them alright ladies put your
[ __ ] Lee press-on nails down let me
finish my goddamn thought here like you
know women get [ __ ] they are into
revenge they are into just making you
[ __ ] life misery so one of the
greatest things you can ever do is you
know something one of these days I'm
gonna have almada wriggle on this
podcast he told me how he used to break
up with women and it was [ __ ]
brilliant in fact he has a great podcast
called minivan men it's him
Maz Jobrani and Chris Spencer they're
all dads they talk about being of dads
and you know but they go off the rails
if they take calls or they have emails
just say
you know put my name in the in the
subject line and just say ask al
Madrigal ask him how to break up with a
woman because he has it [ __ ] down it
was tremendous
but anyways getting back to my point
here
yeah because they'll do everything
they'll do anything they possibly
[ __ ] can you have to make a clean
goddamn break
because when they run out of options and
they're a little tipsy they will they
will do so they'll make out with one of
your friends they'll give him a [ __ ]
hand job but a goddamn Hooters they'll
do something they'll do something and
you know your buddy might not say
anything but she's gonna she's gonna
she's gonna nuke your [ __ ] life if
she's mad enough so okay I agree with
that they create with that definitely um
all right why she's laughing there cuz I
was just totally got away from the list
and I just started talking about my own
fears rather than somebody else's stop
being so selfish bill all right number
four being decapitated yeah that's a bad
one you know especially the way it's
being done
you know those [ __ ] maniacs over the
[ __ ] Afghanistan - if Jesus Christ
that's mean you know you're a psycho
we're gonna decapitate them and you go
over to the goddamn silverware drawer
and you take out a bread knife I'm just
gonna take a while having my ass beat in
public you know that's not something I
really worry about that would be [ __ ]
humiliating now you brought it up he
just added another fear number six
seeing her disappointment after she
unzips my fly yeah that would be a
brutal money you know so does that mean
you have a small dick right now sir or
you're just saying if a girl unzipped
your fly and she was just disappointed
number seven getting stuck in a
neighborhood that doesn't appreciate
whitey late at night
number eight dying alone and you know
something actually getting back to that
other one that whitey late at night you
know most people would help you get out
of the [ __ ] neighborhood in fact one
of the funny things in New York City and
a lot of comedians did bits about this
so I won't joke around about it but when
you were new to the city and you
accidentally got on an express train and
it went from 86th Street up to 125th
Street and they stay with black people
Puerto Ricans they would be looking at
you as a white person to watch you as
you slowly figured out that the train
wasn't stopping at 97th and then a
hundred ten and then whatever the [ __ ]
it went after that went 103 a 105 I
can't [ __ ] remember anymore
and they would just wait and as you went
to get off they would there would always
be somebody anytime I did it even after
I knew what I did and then I knew where
I had to go there would always be
somebody on the train just go you just
want to walk straight across the
platform take the next one down
you know don't talk to anybody don't
look at anybody you know I wonder if
that happens in Kentucky with some poor
black guy gets off at the wrong [ __ ]
exit does some guy named cooter go
listen man you want to get back just
turn it around go right back up that
dirt run telling you that ain't a
bonfire you want to be a part of turn
your [ __ ] turnin arrested Impala god
damn I like this alright turn it around
get it back up to the highway number
eight number eight dying alone you know
that one doesn't scare me I think living
alone is scarier to me dying alone I can
be alright with it you know oh that's
gonna be hilarious me dying is gonna be
funny me trying to remember any prayers
I remember for my [ __ ] religion
that's gonna be a rough one number nine
getting married and regretting it that's
a this is a good list here number ten
having kids
and realizing this is one of the meanest
inks everyone has ever written to me
having kids and realizing one of them is
a redhead no offense but I don't want to
look at that every day Jesus Christ
you know the [ __ ] hatred of redhead
that it never used to be like this that
one [ __ ] South Park episode and just
I think there's a lot of people didn't
even realize I think they didn't even
realize they didn't even like us now all
of a sudden it's unreal feeling like a
[ __ ] Armenian in the middle of Turkey
I don't look at me expanding my horizons
it never happened
if you say it happened you get arrested
that's when you know what happened you
ever hear about that [ __ ] over in Turkey
you can't even you can if you even
suggest that they committed genocide I
want to know more about this by the way
cuz I'm really talking out of my ass
this is just as opposed to you know the
other 40 minutes of this podcast where I
was just completely reading from a fact
book this is the only part of the
podcast where I'm talking out of my ass
yeah if you even bring up that uh that
they committed genocide with uh with the
Armenian people you you automatically go
to jail
if you even bring it up you know I mean
what the [ __ ] people you committed
genocide hey who hasn't you know at some
point you got to admit to it in your own
goddamn way you pay some sort of
reparations you know why don't you give
him some casinos like we did with uh
with all the Native Americans you know
at some point you know you know what
happened to sit there be like it never
happened and if anybody says it happened
you go to jail really right there I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say [ __ ]
happened alright let's go to this next
guy's top ten let's see how many how
much overlap there is losing my teeth
slash dick I find that really
interesting that you put both of those
together now if you asked any guy to
make a choice he would obviously say his
[ __ ] teeth I got to tell you after a
while your dicks gonna get you in way
more trouble than your teeth and you
know you really don't want to [ __ ] when
you're 70 go ahead give me that macho
answer you dumb
you're not your [ __ ] pancreas is
acting up you really want to go and
[ __ ] peel off your cardigan your
wrinkled [ __ ] man tits alright number
two rape of any kind overlap right there
full-blown panic attack while giving a
speech that one I can't relate to I got
over that a long time ago just by what I
do but I remember back in the day when
he had to give a book report I [ __ ]
hated that just sitting there counting
down how many more until I was and
watching somebody give a book report be
be so psyched that it wasn't me and then
when they were done being so jealous
that it was over
awful I used to go up there my face
would turn beet red everyone would be
laughing and I'd feel like an [ __ ] I
was just a [ __ ] parade of humiliation
number four getting beat up in front of
my friends and family there's another
overlap I never think about that [ __ ]
yeah I guess that's uh I know cuz I
don't look at myself like some Chuck
Norris dude like I have some sort of
[ __ ] reputation you know I'm just a
guy who's got a big mouth and talk [ __ ]
and guys like me gets slapped in the
face all the time so it's really not
that much it's like expected you know
[Laughter]
like would you guys be surprised by that
if you heard I did a show and you the
end somebody just jumped on stage and
punched him in the mouth when he bit
yeah you know it kind of makes sense
he's a dick and he's not really
physically imposing so combine that he
looks like Howdy Doody I mean I you know
the math the math really all works out
there I think that's for tough guys
tough guys you know having a loss all
right number five death by Badgers yeah
that's a brutal one I think death by a
badger would actually be even worse than
death by like a grizzly bear because
that would be over quick there'd be like
getting punched by Tyson back in the day
or even now Who am I kidding but death
by a badger that just seems like there
be a lot of there'd be a lot of you know
if you'd be all scratched up like Bruce
Lee and
Enter the Dragon except the scratches
would be real [ __ ] at that thinks it
then nibbling away at you'll waste there
would be a long [ __ ] death um number
six being eaten by a shark
bonus fear sharks starts at the toes I
like this guy this guy has a lot of fear
of being eaten alive like I've always
thought you know if a lion a lioness cuz
the lion doesn't really hunt the lion
ever came running at me once I just
really accepted the fact that I wasn't
gonna get away I would I would think I
think I would grab my collar like Rodney
Dangerfield does to expose more of my
neck just to get it over with quick
those things go right for your neck and
it's done you're [ __ ] it's like it and
choked out in the UFC you're out within
[ __ ] eight seconds so I'm gonna be
worried about that but a shark
first of all shark comes up takes a bite
out of it just to see if you're edible
so there you go there goes your [ __ ]
the the whatever that muscle is on the
back of your leg and then you just [ __ ]
your own pool of your own blood wait for
that [ __ ] to come back and you
can't even see it oh and then it pulls
you on day and you start drowning oh oh
my god oh I would be so mad at God if
that happened the second I was dead and
I was in the way I would even I would
storm right through the way sir you sir
you got to wait your turn I would [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you know when I I would
think that God would have to understand
I would think God would actually be
laughing God sorry about that man but
you know you know what the [ __ ] we doing
in the ocean that my fault
number seven standing naked on stage
while a theater full of women discuss
how small my dick is
[Laughter]
uh guys really have a log I that fear I
don't know I don't know I never think
about that [ __ ] I'm average I still
don't think about that because I always
consider that like that's their last
resort I would be more worried if I
overheard women talking saying I had a
small dick that would bug me that would
that would really [ __ ] bug me you
know and then they saw me catching them
talking and then they tried to play it
off that would bug me because then I
would think that they were serious but
if a girl ever said something might said
to me oh my god she's trying to piss me
off
you know they always go like like when
women try to piss you off the either go
they attack sizee you dick
they question your sexuality or your
sexual prowess is that the word they go
that's usually that's their
three-pronged attack you have a little
dick you suck in bed you're probably gay
you know that's when they just you know
they're just trying to make you mad and
you just you just don't take the bait
you know you know I like my dick I
thought it was a little better than
average I thought I did our right in bed
yeah I thought you came a couple of
times well then you'll enjoy being not
in my life see you sweetie
well you think I'm gay well I'll just
take that as a compliment on my wardrobe
thank you very much don't let the door
hit you yes there you know never take
the bait when they try to make you mad
don't have a [ __ ] do that that's how
Chris Brown ended up in jail you know
when that chick was giving him all that
[ __ ] which I totally believed she was
anybody who has tattooed on their index
finger I mean Jesus Christ is that a
[ __ ] red flag or what right there
that you know that's like you haven't
shut up and listened [ __ ] tattooed on
your [ __ ] fist what woman would go
out with you
you know I blame Chris Brown for that
whole [ __ ] situation he should have
seen that coming
number eight choking to death on a
crouton on YouTube okay it's random
number nine
moving back into my mom's house yeah
that would be brutal it's even worse
with the failure with your mom but all
your neighbors see and you're pulling up
with that you know you little [ __ ] you
go full of clothes number 10 having a
shark badger the same guy having a shark
badger bite my dick off while having a
panic attack onstage in front of my
friends and family all the while it's
streaming live on YouTube
whose audience includes my friends and
family all right so we combined him
there in the end
there you go um and that's fierce for
this week everybody that really seemed
to peter out after a while was it me
does it meet her did it kind of die
um all right here's one for you loner
travel bill since you travel a lot I was
wondering if you have any advice on a
good city to visit for a single guy I'm
34 never married and no kids
ie no baggage even though I like the leg
I'm not looking for a place to go to get
laid just a good place to go visit that
I may have a good Club there may have a
good club or music scene or a good area
with some someone traveling alone won't
feel out of place all right you don't
get laid but you go into a club you must
be into like techno music or something
dude if I was you I just go to Paris
what do you go to Atlanta and look at
another [ __ ] you know I don't know
sports bar I would go to another country
immediately you're interesting because
you're from another place immediately
you have an accent and you got to get
[ __ ] late and if you don't who gives
a [ __ ] you go into a museum you look at
the Li look at the that really average
looking woman that that guy painted from
The Da Vinci Code
evidently she was she was smirking
because she realized that uh I can't
remember she realized something you know
I've never like stood the Mona Lisa I
just I found her arrogant I don't like
that arrogant look on her face I just
think she's got a lot of nerve looking
the way she looks dressing how she
dresses
to have that [ __ ] look in her face um
alright this podcast I don't know what
had what happened to last three minutes
all of us on this podcast sucks it's
going so well
now gives a [ __ ] little my 48 minutes
then can I and it's what's going on here
there we go I'm gonna bomb for the last
12 minutes let me give you guys a
goddamn lesson in bombing all right do
you know what's funny this is how much
this is why I don't gamble by the way
when I lost those first two games before
Jim Harbaugh came to my [ __ ] rescue I
actually shut the TV off and I just I
got my car and I just I tapped out I
can't handle it I don't know how you
[ __ ] gamblers do it I have no [ __ ]
idea how you can't handle it I that the
powerlessness and here it is I got the
NFL package I haven't been home for five
weeks I can finally sit here and watch
the games and because I'm Owen too I
shut it off and I walk away I didn't
watch one second of the 49er game you
know if I won one game early I would
have watched it I would have had a great
[ __ ] time but I didn't I don't know
how you guys do why would you add that
misery deal life
I gotta start talking about that more
for the love of God oh by the way I have
a brand new website everybody let's take
a little tour shall we let's all go to
billboard.com it is up and run and look
at all those fancy photos and eventually
I will get the iPhone so I can start
making videos and putting them up here
and doing all this type of [ __ ] and but
I'm not doing it to the iPhones in the
stores
all right go [ __ ] yourself ghost to
Steve Jobs basically yeah if you write
something on Twitter it shows up over to
the side you can make comments on the
Facebook page if you scroll down you go
all the way down to the bottom of the
page there's your Christmas gift to that
douche you don't like alright you can
get my DVD there we got some mm podcast
t-shirts you go to my bio I got a new
bio sitting there
advance you click on events that's where
uh I'm gonna be you click on the Go
button it'll take you right to where you
need to be to buy tickets unless there's
not a link yet the blog will have the
latest podcast and blogs at some point
if I ever start blogging again the
podcast page will have all my podcasts
eventually we're getting them all what
do we got here we got all the way back
to September gradually getting them up
merchandise page and then the contact
there you go that's the whole thing
we got links to my facebook my Twitter
what the [ __ ] is this speaker thing I
don't know what this is I don't [ __ ]
know
whatever that's that's the deal I got a
new puck I got a new podcast I got a new
website so please visit it please leave
some comments please follow me on
Twitter and that's it i think that's the
podcast for the suite people i don't
have anything else
I have literally run out of funny you
know why because I wasn't ready to do
this one but I was banished by the
lovely beautiful adorable Nia I was
banished down on my goddamn [ __ ]
podcasting place now because she wanted
to watch a TV and she didn't want to
deal with me running my mouth she was
watching that show remember that show
was telling you about last week with
that that lady spent 13 grand on a used
car and tried to talk about how she was
rich hey hey hey yeah she knew I was
gonna run my mouth it's unreal I can't
tell if it's unreal that she kicks me
out or it's unreal that I'm that level
of a dick but I don't know well we're
enjoying the new place that we're living
and nobody above us nobody below us and
that [ __ ] who I lived that old
bastard that I lived above was such a
pain in the ass over the last three four
years that I lived there that every time
I drop something on the floor I actually
I'm waiting to hear him yell and then I
I'm always reminded oh yeah
that douche doesn't live below me
anymore oh by the way by the way I'm
still waiting for my [ __ ] uh what do
you call that thing my deposit I'm still
waiting for it [ __ ] dicks that is
just like just acceptable stealing what
what are the odds imma gonna get my
deposit back or he's gonna owe the dudes
a piece of wallpaper missing that's 900
bucks so go [ __ ] yourself you know it's
like before I move in I have to give you
first and last month before I even move
in I moved out seven [ __ ] weeks ago
I'm severy time I call it oh yeah you
need to talk to Karen in the bookkeeping
yeah I just tried it she's busy she'll
call you back is she gonna call me back
today yes she is never calls me back you
know what the funny thing is is they
think I'm going away I'm not going away
I'm gonna [ __ ] drive down there
tomorrow Happy Thanksgiving
how are you what's going on I want my
[ __ ] money I've called you [ __ ] six
[ __ ] times
you keep saying see I got to get this
out on the podcast because I can't say
that when I'm down there I have to be I
have to you know walk in there yeah yeah
hi yeah I feel poor yeah I just I you
know I moved out of the apartment
complex that you have yeah and I was
wondering you know I've called on
numerous occasion
yeah they haven't yeah well I'm in the
area I don't want to call well can I
wait because I don't want to call
because you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't call me
back
sir you have to leave the building just
give me my [ __ ] money
just give me my [ __ ] money that
[ __ ] place is immaculate [ __ ]
immaculate
I don't want your problem is anybody who
came by the look look at it I raved
about the neighborhood said I loved it I
tried to [ __ ] get her somebody to
rent it out myself what more can I do
give my [ __ ] money
you know I sound right now I sound like
that [ __ ] guy in Goodfellas [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him Izzy I want my money why my
[ __ ] money I old landlord's gonna be
sitting in the back of my Prius and
stick an ice pick in the back of my neck
again I thought he'd never shut up
alright let's go to advice for the week
advice late
at the office wants it okay hey Bill I
was wondering if you and the lovely Nia
if she's around could help me with an
issue I've been having the past couple
of months it has to do with a [ __ ]
lady at work so this girl started at my
office a little over two months ago and
I've been training her on basically
everything so we've been spending a lot
of time together
cue the porno music alright now this
girl is by no means a smoke show but she
is cute and she's the type of girl who
gets more attractive when he gets to
know her because she's pretty cool we
have a lot in common like musical tastes
and we both like the same beer among
other things oh so you've obviously gone
drinking or at the very least you've
discussed you know going out and having
a few you know what's so funny about
that sir you didn't even think of that
question you dicted your dick is always
close and your dick is always in a
two-minute offense you know but you got
to be careful because just like Brett
Favre it will throw back over the middle
for a pick six and I think that that's
what you're about ready to do if you
start banging some broad at work unless
you have the skills let me finish
reading this thing here alright our job
requires a lot of time on the road
oh god this is just totally setup our
job requires a lot of time in the road
so we have a lot of time to talk to each
other while in the car you're in the car
she smells good she's crossing her legs
how many times you gotten a [ __ ] hard
on us you've been driving with her
trying to keep up some stupid
conversation as you dicks going do it do
it anyways a lot of what we've been
talking about is hookup hookups and sex
and what we both like and don't like
dude this is a layup you're in there and
as I could have predicted a bit of
sexual tension began to arise what do
you mean you could have predicted dude
don't [ __ ] play this game with me
alright you know what you're doing a
little bit
actual tension that you [ __ ] created
you're staring the conversation towards
this exactly like you should be doing
this is right down the checklist by the
time I get done reading this should
probably [ __ ] blow a load nur you're
doing everything you can to [ __ ] this
girl anyways what didn't help this
situation was one day when we admit to
each other that we would bang each other
if she didn't have a boyfriend oh Jesus
dude listen before we go any further I
totally respect what you're doing here
all right what I don't respect is the
way you're you're telling it to me as if
this [ __ ] is just happening and you're
not manipulating the situation okay you
totally manipulate in the situation this
is like t-ball this is like [ __ ] t-ball
at this point it's just sitting right
there waiting for you to knock it out of
the park and it was all because of the
excellent [ __ ] work that you've done
all right I'm gonna continue to read
this all right but I want to tell you
and everybody else don't [ __ ] talk to
me like I'm an idiot yeah I used to
think you know and I had the sexual
tension of you because we're sitting
there talking about banging how did you
get on that subject what dumb subject
was she talking about
as you sat there and sort of [ __ ]
force the conversation you know not
forced cuz then she would have known you
just sort of gradually how did you do it
I don't you complement our shoes or
something you know that's always a good
thing you know it's a great [ __ ] way
if you're trying to figure out how to
turn the topic to sex and you're you
know you're not at a bar anything is you
actually compliment another woman that
walks by Bhuvana there's a beautiful
woman
I could really you know and women just
find that fascinating why what do you
like about it bla bla bla bla and you
start with that is the jump off point
and then you're in you know and you're
in you're in okay just don't reach out
and grab her titty in a moment of
[ __ ] reflex though because then
you'll have a problem all right here we
go the sexual tension only got worse as
we talked as we talked about it more
saying what we would do if we ever
hooked up
with each other yeah first of all this
girl does not love her boyfriend and
yeah yeah this is this is over
this is like a [ __ ] red shoe diary at
this point meanwhile when we are in the
office she calls me from her desk from
her desk to mine and sends me email
trying to chitchat and [ __ ] and
basically flirts hardcore see right
there dude right there
right there you just had a meltdown in
the nuclear plant it's starting to spill
over you got to get this girl under
wraps this is bad to the point where
people have asked if there's anything
going on between us you're sloppy you're
young and you're sloppy when we're out
of work she texts me constantly which
gets a little annoying but I'd be a liar
if I didn't like it because I mean who
doesn't like flirting with an attractive
lady you told me before that she wasn't
really that attractive but after a while
she starts getting more attractive what
after she says she wants to suck your
dick you know what this is this chick is
like a virus
and she's already contaminated your
entire workspace this this might be
beyond my help I don't even know where
you're going with this anyways the
situation came to a head one Saturday
night when she text me saying she wants
to be drunk honest with me
I literally said oh Jesus to myself why
you created this situation and he goes
and I asked what she meant she went on
to say she wanted to make out with me
because she's never felt this way about
someone and even though she loves her
boyfriend who she's about to move in
with and plans on marrying she doesn't
think that making out with me is a big
deal I kind of brushed it off as a drunk
text and when she texted me the next day
I asked if she had changed her mind and
she said no and she still wanted to so I
asked so I asked you this sir what the
[ __ ] do I do I know it sucks to be
cheated on because I've been cheated on
and I don't want to do that to this dude
because I've met her boyfriend once and
he's a good guy at the same time he's
not my friend here's where his dick
comes in to argue the other side of it
at the same time he's not my friend and
therefore I feel I need ID I need to be
loyal I don't need to be loyal to him by
not hooking up with his girlfriend I
know be a sleazeball move on my part but
she's old enough to make her own
decisions and she has told me it
wouldn't have it wouldn't affect her
relationship with him oh Jesus dude
whether or not she's actually that's
actually true I won't know unless I go
through with this and wait for the
fallout exactly once again she she told
me she wants to do that she wants to all
she wants to do is make out and not bang
but I know myself and as a 23 year old
guy making out doesn't quite do it for
me anymore so I know I'll try to go
further let me know what you think
thanks in advance love the pod Carrick
all right all right
all right the question you got to ask
you need to ask two questions how much
do you like your job and two can her
boyfriend beat the [ __ ] out of you does
he have any felony convictions or
anything like that because this whole
thing is gonna blow up in your face this
is a confused woman she doesn't know
what she wants to do she doesn't how to
be in a relationship she's [ __ ] she's
actually using you and you guys are
going to [ __ ] you might not [ __ ] the
first time but you're gonna [ __ ] and
then you're gonna [ __ ] on a regular
basis unless you decide you don't want
to and it's gonna get weird this is one
of these girls no matter what it's gonna
get [ __ ] weird so alright I don't
know what to tell you here because I
don't know all the details but the smart
move here is to not [ __ ] this woman okay
people already know there's sexual
tension so if you know she has a
boyfriend they know she has a boyfriend
and you're just gonna look like a piece
of [ __ ] and the whole thing's gonna blow
up and it's gonna be gossip and you have
any sort of like desire to move up in
that country your country that company
you're really gonna [ __ ] screw that
aspect of it up there's plenty of
[ __ ] women you're 23 years old you're
in the prime
[ __ ] life go out and [ __ ] somebody
else alright and that whole thing there
you know she's got a boyfriend and you
know but blah blah blah blah blah I
agree with you that's not your [ __ ]
fault okay but the thing about it is
what makes it weird is you're gonna see
this girl again the next day and the
next day and the next day you know
what's gonna happen he's you know you're
in your head you can be like yeah we
just [ __ ] cuz she said we're just
[ __ ] and she said it isn't a big deal
because she said it isn't a big deal and
you know what she's gradually gonna suck
you when do having a [ __ ]
relationship with her and you're gonna
have to having a breakup with somebody
that you're not even going out with at
[ __ ] work and then she's gonna make
your life a living hell
this [ __ ] girl not only could she not
keep her goddamn legs closed you know
she can't keep her [ __ ] mouth shut
she's gonna talk to somebody else and
the whole thing is gonna [ __ ] blow up
alright
so my advice to you is don't [ __ ] this
girl have a mature conversation with her
and say look it'd be one thing if you
were single but you're not you have a
boyfriend I feel bad I met the guy you
want to move in with them you want to
get married this is the way you do just
say I just I really find you attractive
I would really love to hook up with you
but I just I can't I wasn't raised that
way you just back out of it that way and
just get the [ __ ] out of it man I'm
telling you unless you haven't been laid
in a while and you don't give a [ __ ]
about your job then just [ __ ] bang
her right on your goddamn desk in front
of the security cameras you know put
your website Rutt write it on your back
[Laughter]
and you know what [ __ ] come right in
her face
give this dirty [ __ ] what she [ __ ]
deserves you know but other than that
I'm telling you the downfall of men
it's our dicks i dicks get us and more
[ __ ] goddamn trouble than anything
else and if you can somehow make a
rational decision despite the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] your dick is saying
dick is like that diva wide receiver on
the football team screaming for the ball
every other play you know and you know
goddamn well it's double coverage okay
all you need to do is just [ __ ] wind
down the last two minutes of the game
and there's you [ __ ] douche screaming
at you what are you gonna do you know
that's a tough one that's really a tough
one but I'm but you know if you're gonna
break up with her just act like you're
an honorable human being and just say I
can't do it cuz you have a boyfriend
just say like you believe it and then
get out of it and I and you watch you
watch what happens okay they're still
gonna be fallout to that and just it
just feels like weird like you're not
like talking to me anymore [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you're psycho you already have a
situation on your hands please buy me by
the way I'm actually invested in this
emotionally now I want to know what
happens please let me know if you [ __ ]
her if you don't [ __ ] her what happens
what doesn't happen and all that all
right um Jesus Christ Jesus gots a
[ __ ] situation anyways alright last
thing I'm gonna read here
Jesus hour and 10 minutes here we go
kill me is the last thing so I'm 28 and
work in education and I gotta tell you
why there are no men in education not
only is there no money in it but every
day I'm surrounded by these women and
they suck out my [ __ ] life force
don't get me wrong whenever I say these
women you would think it would be great
oh don't get me wrong when I say these
women you would think would be great I
work in a night at a nice College the
people are nice there's young tail
everywhere why I took the job okay
alright alright here we go here's
another Penn State [ __ ] situation but
every day I want to shoot myself in the
[ __ ] head let me tell you why there
are three men in the office we are
outnumbered fifteen to one it's me my
boss and one other do dude who might be
gay but either way in my office but
either way my boss's office is on the
other side of the department so it's
and about 20 chicks and their constant
chick conversation about the stupidest
crap for the majority of the day yeah
you're basically like some woman who
doesn't like sports in a sports bar I'm
gonna have to listen to a bunch of idiot
guys going dude you know I'll tell you
if on the Jets oh I got to be thinking
they're firing on all still don't all
day you're in the urine need the reverse
of that situation anyways most days I
ignore it I just sit in my little
[ __ ] cubicle I put on my music and
bang out my work but every once in a
while some of this [ __ ] happens to
infect my eardrums and mine [ __ ] me for
the rest of the day
case in point today it's Monday and I
spent most of the day catching up on all
the [ __ ] I didn't do when I left the
office early on for when I left the
office early on Friday so it was a busy
day but at 4:40 I'm caught I'm all
caught up and tired so I'm just [ __ ]
around searching for random [ __ ] on the
internet for my last for my last twenty
minutes you know when is Bill burr
coming to Seattle etc while I'm trying
to tune everybody out and just go
through the last 20 minutes of them a
day of my day without committing suicide
I hear oh my god that is like the
greatest idea ever I absolutely need one
of those
so okay I find myself invested a little
bit a little bit what could it be the
greatest idea ever I am intrigued I
don't say [ __ ] but I'm curious I'm
thinking you absolutely need one huh
okay what could it be
maybe my girlfriend will want one
christmas is coming up uh pretty soon
more girls join in over in the cubicle
next to me oh what a great idea oh yeah
my friend Lizzy bought one of those it's
terrific so I listen over my cubicle
wall and I'm like dammit what the [ __ ]
sounds great I spent five minutes of my
life totally invested what what could it
be
tell me you [ __ ] [ __ ] so what is
it and I look it's a [ __ ] scarf
organizer eight bucks at IKEA look it up
if you're a I couldn't [ __ ] believe
it I never get that five minutes of my
life back it's not that I'm pissed off
much because I let them pull me in to
their stupid [ __ ] chick world for a
minute but I was so invested I am forced
to retain some of this stupid [ __ ] that
I hear I mean someday when I'm married
and my wife comes to me with some
[ __ ] like honey I have too many
scars I don't know what to do and before
today I would have said you know what
you need to do you need a [ __ ] coat
rack yeah I'll put a 2x4 on the wall
maybe put some nails in it you're good
to go
you can hang hats and scarves and all
your [ __ ] problem solved or maybe you
know what you need a trip to the [ __ ]
good we'll get rid of some of that [ __ ]
Jesus this guy's hardcore but now
whenever I hear some random woman
[ __ ] like this in the back of my
mind I hear IKEA $8 they got the perfect
part product somebody please kill me
yeah dude that's a tough situation
[Music]
that's a tough I can you know it I can't
even remember and all that if you still
single or not I guess you are still
single you know it's so funny you know
what's so funny is after I told that
other guy not to bang the person or work
you should [ __ ] one of those girls at
work you know just take out all that
angst for them wasting your time and
just give them a strong seven minutes
[Music]
all right I got nothing what do I got
our and [ __ ] eleven minutes here
underrated overrated for the week
underrated beers in the shower nothing
better than finishing the work and have
finishing work and having a beer also
nothing better than finishing work and
having a shower combine the two and
you're the most more relaxed and having
a a pull without the effort of getting
of getting hard sorry I butchered the
reading of that you know actually talked
about some guy in intervention who
described starting his day drinking a
beer in the shower which I thought was
disgusting and by the time he was done I
was like that's the greatest beer
commercial I've ever seen in my life or
heard I should say overrated taking a
lady on a date to see your show don't
get me wrong the antisocial Network
Comedy Tour was awesome oh you mean my
show you guys were [ __ ] hilarious but
as an average dude with an average dick
and a tiny bank account
all I've got to give
me and edges my sense of humor and after
a few hours of laughing her ass off at
the show she was so stretched out by the
proverbial 12-inch comedy [ __ ] that you
guys are swinging
she couldn't even feel me ah yeah now
she could have dude you just got yeah
she could have done come on you gonna
make me feel guilty cuz I went up there
and dance like a monkey wasn't my fault
I opened all right don't blame me blame
those other beasts on the show alright
that's it well we kind of petered out
there in the ending didn't we didn't we
go [ __ ] yourselves that's the podcast
for this week I hope you guys I hope you
enjoyed it I hope I made you laugh I do
one of these every Monday if you're new
to my new to my podcast I probably
should have said at the beginning the
official podcast page of the of the
Monday morning podcast is type in WWE
mm podcast calm you can send emails
there there's a donation button we got a
ringtone somewhere on there that nobody
can find for some reason and that's it
DVDs and I got Nooh Monday morning
podcast t-shirts on Bill burr comm if
you like to buy those and if you don't I
don't give a [ __ ] you know I'm not
trying to break your bank not trying to
break your balls you know you want one
[ __ ] get one you don't don't I don't
give a [ __ ] all right that's the podcast
for this week let's go Patriots win by
you